DANNY KOKER: Man, when we got in
I love this car.
And frankly, I really
wanted to keep it.
So can I have it?
But it's not mine, man.
It belongs to a cat
named Mark, brought
it in for a simple paint job.
Well, simple is just something
we don't do very well here.
So I got with Ryan
and figured out a way
to add a little bit of
that Count's Kustoms flavor
to this gorgeous Chevy.
Ryan did some amazing
pinstripe into this Chevy
that I'm really hoping is just
going to blow Mark's mind away.
After you, Mark.
Thank you.
DANNY KOKER: Now, on the
other hand, if he hates it,
I suppose I'll just be
forced to add a beautiful '55
Nomad to my collection.
When you brought this car
in, she was beautiful.
And that's always scary.
Taking apart a beautiful
car and redoing it,
which always makes me nervous.
You ready, brother?
- I'm ready.
Are you ready?
I am ready.
DANNY KOKER: Rock and roll.
Here we go.
Ryan!
Come on, man.
Bring out my Nomad.
I mean, Mark's Nomad.
[laughter]
[instrumental music playing]
I'm gettin' chills right now.
Wow.
That's the sound.
I remember.
[laughter]
Woo, let me catch my breath.
Soak it up, brother.
Ryan, I know you know Mark--
- Mark, good to see you again.
- Mark, I know you know Ryan.
- Good to see you, man.
MARK: Wow.
Man, that is just amazing.
DANNY KOKER: We took
this classic 1955
Chevy Nomad from pale purple
to beautiful brandywine.
I didn't think she could look
much better than she did,
but, man, was I wrong.
The Tri-Fives beg for
that two-tone look.
Other than the
addition of disc brakes
and a beautiful polish and some
re-chrome under the brightwork,
she was good to go.
Mark had a great
car to begin with,
but we kept with his wishes
of keeping it simple.
But we couldn't help
ourselves, and added
some subtle pinstriping at
the front nose and louvers,
to bring this baby to an
all-new level of cool.
Looking good?
MARK: You hit it
out of the park.
RYAN: Luckily, you had
that million dollar body.
We expected, you know,
a vehicle like this
to have rust all over it.
Very little rust.
The biggest task on this
was your engine bay.
The engine bay--
- Well--
RYAN: --when you brought it in--
- --that was my next question.
It looked like it had been
rolled with black paint.
It probably was.
Oh, bro you're--
Not anymore.
DANNY KOKER: Are
you ready for this?
You notice anything?
MARK: Ugh.
DANNY KOKER: We took a chance.
I know you said, I
don't want pinstripe.
I don't want to do
anything like that.
But it just needs a little.
I like it.
[laughter]
RYAN: You like it?
- Very classy.
The pinstriping is good?
No, I like it.
It's old school
hot-rod right there.
- We can keep it?
- We're keepin' it.
I don't have to take it off.
DANNY KOKER: You don't
have to take it off.
[laughter]
While you're liking that,
take a look at all your louvers.
Each louver also has that
same color in the pinstripe.
You can hardly even tell.
That is so subtle.
DANNY KOKER: Yeah.
You get this thing
out in the sun
and you'll notice
every one of those.
Man, that is just amazing.
DANNY KOKER: Check this out.
RYAN: This is the best.
DANNY KOKER: You're
gonna love this, man.
Bam.
RYAN: Brandywine and chrome.
DANNY KOKER: Holding hands.
MARK: Wow.
Now, while we were in here,
OK, we pulled the engine out.
We pulled everything out.
So that Ryan and
his team could get
in this beautiful engine bay.
And then, you can
see your new grille.
All of the brightwork.
All of the chrome.
All that everything has
been redone on her, man.
You feel good about it?
MARK: I feel really
good about it.
She's just beautiful.
DANNY KOKER: I don't have one.
I've always wanted one.
- Oh, here we go.
- I was--
[laughter]
- I know.
If you ever get to that point
in your life and you just go,
you know, I think I'm just
going to let the Nomad go,
I hope, I hope, I'm your
first number you call.
MARK: You have--
DANNY KOKER: I love this car.
MARK: --first right of refusal.
DANNY KOKER: You're beautiful.
You're beautiful.
I'm really gonna miss this car,
to be honest with you, man.
I loved having this
thing in the shop.
I think, frankly, I might
need to go Nomad shopping.